so as we continue our discussion on DC
rebirth what I want to do here is pick
up with Detective Comics now I know I'm
a little bit behind here I know that um
you know this story's largely been
covered by almost everybody simply
because it's a Batman title and that
usually happens you know whenever DC
releases you know a reboot or a refresh
of their continuity Batman and Superman
are usually always the first two to be
targeted uh just because they're you
know for the most part the two most
popular superheroes the two have ever
existed in the history of comic books
but for me Detective Comics really
highlights the great aspects the Great
aspects of the uh of the DC rebirth
event and what I mean here is you know
DC rebirth uh is designed to take what
worked with the new 52 and combine it
with what worked in the pre- new52
continuity to create something wholly
new right it's designed to grab us as
the reader to take the things we love
and to bring it together into one
cohesive continuity now Detective Comics
actually focuses or initially opens up
with the with Batman or I guess with the
character of Azrael now in DC Comics
Azrael is actually kind of a mixed bag
when it comes to Fanfare there are some
who love him there are some that don't
really care care for him uh but it's
undoubtable that he is a well-known name
in DC Comic circles regardless of which
Circle you come from but the fact
remains here that Azrael took the place
of Bruce Wayne or I guess as Batman uh
you know following Bruce Wayne's back
being broken by Bane during the
Nightfall or Nightfall story arc in the
early 1990s but the issue with this is
that following this particular storyline
uh you know Azrael never really seemed
to quite gain the same kind of Fame he
had before uh you know going from taking
the role of Batman to being relegated to
being an assassin you know and that kind
of thing just didn't really resonate
with readers and so the problem was that
Jean Paul Valley basically kind of
disappeared from the DC landscape you
know in the beginning shortly after nigh
Hall he wasn't really out of the game
but he was certainly being handed his
hat and it got to the point where he was
just pushed out of the game in his
entirety now it remained this way in DC
Comics even going into the new 52 uh
until we saw Batman and Robin Eternal
and that was when um when John Paul
Valley made his return now this was
actually kind of cool because what Scott
Snider did here is he basically took the
element of Jean Paul Valley and he
largely kept it the same simply because
the version that appeared during
Nightfall and shortly after was the one
that everybody was the most familiar
with and so it made sense you know to to
take that version and to roll him over
and give people the one they're familiar
with and then if changes were going to
be made make those changes shortly
thereafter the issue with this is that
again you know Jean Paul Valley just
sort of stayed behind I mean he wasn't a
great big huge character he was one of
many faces that appeared in the uh in
the Eternal line of stories and so what
happens here with DC rebirth is we see a
lot of the same thing that we've seen
before you know Jean Paul Valley is
still operating as an assassin for St
Dumas you know he still has a Handler so
on and so forth but he's really more of
a catalyst in this story which is kind
of the the role that he prominently
plays he he's basically a way for
writers to set up future events that are
going to be coming and this is exactly
what happens with uh with Jean Paul
Valley you know of course he's dealing
with Batman Batman's you know facing off
against him and so on but in the midst
of their conversation in the midst of
their of their conflict somebody's
watching the two of them now we don't
really know who this person is off the
top of their head which of course we'll
find out later on but at the same time
while Batman is trying to subdue Jean
Paul Jean Paul Valley ultimately Jean
Paul Valley is incapacitated and when
Batman deduces word came from he
realizes that it's a drone now we'll
follow this line of thought to its
completion here in a little while but
what we do is we actually transfer over
to Batwoman herself now this is one of
the things I love the most about
Detective Comics because this is the new
52 batom you know this is not the
pre-new 52 version so this version hails
from a military family she spent time in
the military she was uh not really a
person who led a unit per se so much as
she was someone that knew how to work as
a team which would be a major focal
point you know for the the story of
Detective Comics but the fact remains
here that she's in a conversation with
what appears to be her father and her
father says that basically she's she's
taken the wrong direction here now
something to point out here is that uh
is that batom was never officially part
of the bat family she was but she wasn't
she was part of the bat family in terms
of her name but she was actually offered
a position by Bruce Wayne as part of
Batman Incorporated which was Bruce's
attempt to kind of make like an
international bat Force so to speak and
she turned that that offer down and the
result was that she basically kind of
operated as a vigilante on her own
dealing with criminals and various
characters that would normally go
unnoticed or you know without without
being uh taken care of by the
traditional bat family of Batgirl and
Batman and you know Robin and so on and
so forth and so the conversation she has
with her father here uh gives us some
insight what he basically says is that
batom was in a position when she was in
the US military to continue her training
to the point where she would have led a
unit and quite possibly progressed up
the ranks especially considering the
fact that her father was in the military
uh the issue with this is that because
she chose to go off and become a
vigilante uh ultimately she seems to
have turned her back or her father feels
as though she turned her back on
everything her family stood for and so
the result is that you know with the two
of them uh more or less arguing or or
failing to see you know each other's
views uh what we're given here is this
perspective that you know Batwoman does
not see eye to eye with her father
there's there really doesn't seem to be
any love loss between the two of them
and so once they hang up she's
immediately met by the arrival of Batman
now this is why I say batom was never
officially part of the bat family no
Kathy Kane was never part of the bat
family as we would view it it the whole
basis behind this is that during Bruce
Wayne or during Batman's conversation
with her he basically says you know kind
of gives a rundown of Jean Paul Valley
really for us as the reader for those of
us who weren't familiar with his
character but that while Batman had you
know been trying to uh more at least it
seemed to be trying to get Jean Paul
Valley to his side uh in the end you
know Jean Paul Valley chose not to see
things that way but was incapacitated by
an unseen Force after which Batman
deduced that a drone had been initiated
which had launched a strike against
azreel and when Batman Tracked Down the
Drone he hacked into its circuit
circuitry and realized it was basically
part of a swarm now the reason why he
brought this information to to Batwoman
was because of the fact that she was
part of the military more so than that
she has access to military grade
technology and various forms of
technology that Bruce Wayne might not
have access to due to the fact that he's
basically a civilian whereas you know
batom spent time at a as a citizen and
so the issue here is that Batman's you
know this technology this drone is about
10 years ahead of current technology
that exists out there right now now
we're not told explicitly if this is uh
technology as a whole in terms of of you
know in the world as it exists right now
or if it's simply military technology
but a general rule of thumb is that when
the general public is able to gain
access to a form of Technology the
military's already had it for quite some
time and so on the surface it seems as
though this technology is military in
nature and so what happens is Batman
basically goes to tells Batwoman there's
a much bigger issue going on here
Whoever has access to this technology is
in a position whereby they seem to be
operating from the Shadows more so than
that there seems to be a looming threat
on the horizon that Batman can't quite
figure out on his own or at the very
least deal with on his own and so what
he's done is he's basically come to
batom for the purpose of petitioning her
to not really militarize so much as
bring together the remnants of the bat
family who were not off doing their own
thing which is to say Nightwing Batgirl
so on to basically bring together the
ancillary members of the bat of the bat
family and kind of whip them into shape
and turn them into a solid team now
again this aspect of Kathy Kane not
really being part of the bat family
comes in the fact that Bruce Wayne
Reveals His identity to her now his
expectation is that she doesn't know who
he is but she had already figured it out
in addition to this the they're actually
cousins for those of you guys who uh
weren't wildly familiar with uh with
Batman's continuity and so you know
while the uh while Martha Wayne was kind
of the link between the two of them this
aspect of their relationship you know in
terms of being siblings will actually
become a pretty significant Point uh
over the course of the story but the
fact remains here that what we get is
this sort of tour of the different
people who are going to be brought into
this team uh under the training of
Batwoman now we don't really need to go
into each of them in depth uh simply
because of the fact that there'll be
expansions on their characters later on
but somebody that the story will focus
on later on is uh is spoiler is
Stephanie Brown now we also learn this
team is going to consist of Tim Drake
who is currently operating under the
mantle of Red Robin now for those of you
guys who don't know uh Tim Drake was of
course Robin he fought alongside Batman
for a time but much like Dick Grayson
much like Damen Wayne or what will
probably become of Damen Wayne uh you
know much like Jason Todd Tim Drake sort
of struck out on his own now Jason
Todd's a little bit different of a
situation simply because he was killed
but the fact remains here that you know
Tim Drake struck out on his own much
like Dick Grayson to become his own hero
Red Robin and so while he's still there
as part of the bat family he doesn't
really operate in the same capacity as
you would expect to see a Robin fighting
alongside uh Batman but the fact remains
that the ties between the two of them
are still very close and in fact this
story will basically say that uh that
that Tim Drake is the best of them that
Tim Drake is the most capable of them in
terms of its technology now the next of
these is a uh is a character named
orphan now orphan again is not really a
robin she's really more of a character
that was kind of brought in at the
behest of of Bruce Wayne to sort of
operate as a Black Ops agent so to speak
going into places that Batman that the
other Robins simply couldn't access on
their own but nonetheless the entire
basis behind this is that we're seeing a
kind of a symo of sorts now in Oddball
this actually thrown into this team
comes in the form of Clayface and this
is one of the reasons why the detective
line of stories seems to be so cool in
terms of how it's being brought to us
with a character of Clayface or uh or
basil Carlo we would just kind of uh
chalk him up as an incable villain he's
been a longtime foe of Batman but in
this detective line of comics he's
looking for Redemption he's looking to
sort of return himself to normaly now a
lot of this is psychological a lot of
this is because of the fact that
Clayface just simply doesn't want to be
a bad guy anymore the repetition of
fighting Batman being thrown in Arkham
Asylum escaping and going back in again
uh seems to really sort of take away
from his desire to live and so what
happens is he's basically uh you know in
a theater had essentially ran everybody
out for the purpose of just watching a
movie of himself by himself you know
without being disturbed and he's greeted
by the arrival of both Batman and batom
now because of the fact that Clayface is
looking for Redemption because of fact
that he's looking to make up for his
past misdeeds Batman and Batwoman offer
him this option but only under the
condition that he does what it is that
they're told and so from here for the
next little bit of the story we get
somewhat of a of a kind of training
montage of sorts in the sense that we
see Red Robin we see that orphan we see
that that uh you know Stephanie Brown
spoiler that all these forces you know
all these individuals are essentially
training they're learning how to work as
a team but we're also finding that they
all have individual weaknesses and their
weaknesses that could in effect cause
them to end up losing a battle or even
losing their lives in the process the
issue with Stephanie Brown according to
Batwoman is that um you know she is
she's someone that has all kinds of
capable moves but she never trained her
body to practice those moves for the
Long Haul meaning that she doesn't have
stamina that can allow her to you know
stay fighting using her particular form
of fighting for the Long Haul now this
isn't a bad thing simply because she's
able to incapacitate you know a small
number of people in a very short amount
of time but the issue that batwoman's
bringing up is what happens if she has
to fight 50 people or 100 people she
won't have the Sima to keep that going
uh orphan is very capable in terms of
fighting ability but the problem with
this is that orphan tries to fight
everybody's battles because orphan is so
capable as a fighter in addition to this
Clayface really doesn't have any any
fighting fundamentals whatsoever and
this is largely because of the fact that
Clayface usually uh uses his his Mal
ability to create stabbing weapons to
create daggers you know objects he can
easily cut through individuals and so he
never really had to learn how to fight
but the question that uh that Batwoman
brings up is what would happen if he did
learn how to fight just as good as as
her or spoiler or or orphan or Batman
you know in that instance Clayface would
become a formidable threat if his body
hardened automatically in order to
prepare for contact for uh you know
different punches and things like that
now again this isn't wildly important uh
important stuff this is really just us
being told as the reader that the two of
them were I guess this this group is
kind of fleshing out what it is that
makes them weak fleshing out these
things that that sort of seem to take
away from that now from here we actually
end up jumping to uh to a woman named
Leslie Thompson now Leslie Thompson is
of course again working I believe is
part of uh St deas but Leslie Thompson
is is more she's more akin to like Night
Nurse from Marvel Comics in the sense
that she basically uh helps different
superheroes different people deal with
their own injuries she's closely
associated with the bat family more so
than anybody else it doesn't mean that
she doesn't make appearances with other
superheroes but you're more inclined to
see her in a Batman comic than you are
anywhere else but the fact remains here
that uh both Bruce Wayne and Tim Drake
have traveled here to gain what
information they can from Jean Paul
Valley just because of the fact that his
his travels as an assassin would preview
him to information that they simply
wouldn't be able to get a hold of on
their own now what he says is that
there's some organization operating out
there called The Colony they don't
really know what the colony is or he
doesn't really know a whole lot about
the colony all he knows is that they
seem to be operating from the shadows
and they appear to be operating under
the oses of taking Gotham by force now
there something else that I also want to
point out something I want you to take
note of is a conversation that happens
between Batman and Tim Drake and things
like this we're going to put a lot of
emphasis on in this video because these
are pretty important what Batman does is
sort of have a a heart-to-heart
discussion or at least as close of a
heart-to-heart discussion as Bree Wayne
can have with Tim Drake and what he says
is that Tim is extremely capable Tim has
uh has always kind of carved out a niche
for himself you know he's able to hold
his own in a multitude of different ways
but Tim Drake always sort of wanted to
move away from being Batman because he
didn't want to end up like Bruce Wayne
but more so than that what what Bruce
says is that there's always a place for
him to come back if he wants to that the
city of Gotham is safer if uh if Red
Robin is operating if Tim Dr is
operating within the city now this is a
huge amount of respect from from Batman
because what he's basically saying is
that Tim Drake is every bit as good as
he is and there's truth to this you know
Tim Drake is every bit as capable as
Batman sure Batman has more money he's
got a little more experience and if the
two of them fought against one another
Batman would probably win with a little
bit of an edge but it doesn't mean that
he would walk all over Tim Drake Tim
Drake would put up one hell of a fight
but the fact remains here that Tim Drake
also has a relationship going on with
Stephanie Brown and this is really cool
because it gives us a little more meat
and potatoes to things that are going on
it shows us that not all of these
members of this uh extended bat family
are just operating side by side without
any real connection instead they have a
romantic relationship they are very much
in love with one another now from here
we pick up with Bruce Wayne as he's
making his way back to the Batcave but
before he can arrive he's actually set
upon by what appear to be some enemy
forces most likely these individuals
belonging to the Colony and so while
they taunt him while they initially say
that they'll take him out Batman seems
to be the kind of hero who would get the
upper hand he would most likely be able
to hold his own here but once everything
seems to come to an end and once the
rest of the bat family to analyze the
situation they also come to the
realization that Batman seems to have
been completely incapacitated by these
forces of the colony they seem to be
trained in military tactics they have
access to Advanced Technology they are
for all intents and purposes or seem for
all intents and purposes to have been
designed to be equal to Batman if not
Superior to Batman and so again this is
really just more of an analysis on
behalf of these extended bat member
families and so with Tim Drake and
Batwoman analyzing the situation and
realizing that if Bruce Wayne was taken
out that this is a very serious Force
they basically begin calling together
the various members we see them calling
together uh orphan they bring together
uh Clayface they bring in Stephanie
Brown it's it's really kind of an all
handson deck sort of situation in
addition to this what batom also does is
she calls her father now this is done by
her because of the fact that these guys
have military training and so even if
her father doesn't know exactly where
these guys came from what he would know
is what kind of tactics they're using or
what kind of Technology they have and
perhaps give them information on that
technology the problem with this this is
that it's actually revealed that her
father is the one behind all of this
that her father is the one that's
actually leading the colony with
intentions that weren't initially
explained to us now these intentions are
actually given to us later on and what
he says here is that for him Batman
represents fear Batman represents
motivation for criminals to not break
the law now it doesn't mean that
Batman's an absolute truth it doesn't
mean that all criminals will avidly
avoid Batman what it does mean is that
he's extremely capable in terms of his
martial arts train his tactics and his
uh his stealth uh subfusion and so on
and so forth everything that makes him
who he is and so because Batman had been
taken prisoner by The Colony they
actually began breaking down his utility
belt and analyzing everything inside of
it which again gives them some very
significant uh benefits in terms of what
their goal is and what we're told is
that the goal of the colony is to
actually use Batman's technology to use
his role in Gotham on a much larger
scale that instead of Simply fighting
criminals and then sending them away
that instead they want to basically
eliminate elate criminals in their
entirety now again this this does not
explain why it is that Colonel Kan or
why it is that that Kathy Kane's father
is implementing this in the first place
and it's never truly explained to us in
this story it may simply be that he's
being pulled or I guess the strings of
his actions are being pulled by somebody
else or it may never be explained but
because DC rebirth is so tight on
continuity it would make sense that we
would get an explanation at some future
point in time and so what happens is
that b while Batman is able to escape
his prison while he is able to uh to
move way and begin able to I guess take
out these various uh these various
forces in the end once he once he
confronts Colonel Cain you know once
they begin having this conversation
about being an heir to the League of
Shadows Batwoman basically shows up
along with the rest of the extended bat
family and do everything they can to
begin fighting these forces off now this
is when the death of Tim Drake begins to
come into play here while these forces
are able to fight off you know the
colony while while you know the extended
bath family is able to hold their own
within reason the issue here is that the
The Colony has begun plans to basically
begin taking out various people most
notably the bat family now it doesn't
mean kill them it simply means
incapacitate them so that they won't be
part of a part of a bigger issue more so
than that Colonel Kane has kind of
reached this level of insanity where
he's basically adopted this mindset
where they have to raise the city of
Gotham in order to rebuild it which is
to say tear it down and create something
better and so because of this Tim Drake
goes through then actually reprograms
the drones in order to not Target
anybody else and to Target him directly
the problem with this is that it's seems
to inevitably result in the death of Tim
Drake now something that I'd like you to
take note of here and this is something
that I actually didn't realize until one
of you guys had posted a comment down in
the comment section in my video on
Action Comics in that series when we had
talked about who was Clark Ken we had
mentioned that there was a man who was
wearing a plaid shirt who had a hat who
had a beard but we didn't know who he
was he was very mysterious and we didn't
know what was going on with him this man
actually appears here and he seems to be
watching all these events that are
unfolding all these events that are
taking place now again this is just kind
of a nod this is just kind of a uh of a
small indication that there may be a
much bigger picture taking place but in
the end uh this is really all just a
situation whereby the target is Gotham
City and the goal of the bat family is
to basically save Gotham and so what
they do or at least what Batman does is
he recalls the extended members of the
bat family brings them all back to uh to
his location in order to ensure that all
of them will remain safe from uh from
these drones and can plan accordingly
the issue with this is that because Tim
Drake had reprogrammed the drones he
made himself the sole Target and so he
is inevitably going to die in this now
this is actually a beautiful moment as
it's written here in Detective Comics
and this is why I love this story so
much this is Tim Drake giving his last
goodbyes this is Tim Drake telling
Batman that it was an honor to fight
beside him that he always loved being
Robin that if anybody needs to live here
it needs to be Batman simply because of
the fact that Batman is so wildly
intelligent that Batman is so capable
but more so than that he sends his love
basically to Stephanie Brown telling her
that while he had somewhat of a uh of a
rough experience growing up while he had
somewhat of a very rough childhood while
Batman was able to give him a place give
him a direction to go to in order to
carve out his own niche in the world in
the end he was still very much alone
Stephanie Brown had basically given him
a reason to keep going that her love for
him showed the kind of life that he
could lead and so saying his last
goodbyes to her is not something that
she wants to hear but in the end before
she can respond before she can get him
to more or less come to senses Tim Drake
severs Communications between the two of
them and is essentially attacked by the
drones who again have sought after him
and killed him as their target or at
least it's believed that they had killed
him as their target now to the rest of
the bat family to Batman to to Clayface
to you know to Alfred to Duke Thomas to
Stephanie Brown you know even Nightwing
and everybody who was listening on Tim
Drake was believed to have been dead he
was believed to have been killed off but
what we actually learn here is that this
is not the case instead Tim Drake seems
to have been whisked away by some
individual that we're not sure who this
person is now this is not the first time
we've seen this guy this guy actually
appeared in Action Comics when he was
watching the events unfold in the fight
between the pre- new52 Superman and the
pre- new 52 doomsday then this unknown
person kept saying things about how a
human Clark Kent shouldn't exist that
doomsday should not exist in the new 52
the pre 52 Superman should not exist in
the new 52 and so this person seems to
have this idea that they're effectively
going to create or I guess fix the uh
fix the timeline or they're going to do
something to adjust it we don't really
know what Direction it is that DC is
going with this what we do know is that
this person seems to serve as one part
of a much bigger picture he seems to
serve as one one part of a much larger
situation that will likely come with the
first I guess the the the huge line wide
crossover that DC has presumably
following the events of uh Justice
League versus Suicide Squad but with
that being said let me know what you
guys think about uh about Detective
Comics because in my mind this story is
beautifully written it's it's one of the
absolute best stories that that I've
seen so far and I think this is a real
Testament to how well DC rebirth is
being done by DC Comics to how well
they're they're really taking these
continuities you know from The pre- New
52 and The New 52 combining them
together and taking us on one hell of a
ride when it comes to storytelling but
with that being said uh if you guys are
new here hit hit the like button uh hit
the sub button to become part of the
robore and leave a comment below let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]
oh